Trascrizione: Alessia R
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Questo è il genoma di un toscano:
ma potrebbe essere tranquillamente
il genoma di ciascuno di noi.
Vedete i 23 cromosomi che lo compongono,
tra cui uno è il cromosoma X,
che è uno dei cromosomi sessuali,
che determina il sesso con cui nasciamo.
Per ognuno di questi cromosomi,
abbiamo una copia da parte di mamma
e una copia da parte di papà,
qui rappresentate con queste
due sequenze di A-G-C-T,
le basi che compongono appunto il DNA.
Vedete che ho evidenziato
delle piccole zone,
in questo genoma in blu?
Queste sono zone -
sono dei piccoli frammenti,
che sono abbastanza rari
nelle popolazioni umane:
ognuno di questi, se non altro,
è abbastanza raro.
E per questo motivo,
quando noi abbiamo uno
di questi frammenti a quelle posizioni,
tendiamo a differire dalla maggior parte
delle persone che ci circondano.
Per questo motivo, come vedete,
la mamma e il papà di questo individuo
gli hanno lasciato due cromosomi
essenzialmente diversi.
Ma cos'è che rende
davvero speciali questi frammenti?
Beh, se andiamo a vedere il cromosoma
lasciato a questo individuo
dalla mamma o dal papà,
è identico al genoma di Neanderthal.
Questo non riguarda solo
il nostro amico toscano,
ma riguarda tutti noi:
per alcuni pezzi del vostro genoma,
alcuni di questi frammenti sono più simili
a quelli di un Neanderthal,
vissuto magari 50.000 anni fa
in una grotta in Croazia,
che a quelli del vostro vicino di sedia.
Magari adesso vi starete chiedendo:
oddio, cosa vuol dire,
che mia mamma o mio papà
erano Neanderthal?
Allora, per evitare drammi familiari,
andiamo a vedere chi erano i Neanderthal.
I Neanderthal li conosciamo
per i loro utensili,
che erano essenzialmente più semplici
di quelli del Sapiens
nello stesso periodo di tempo;
e li riconosciamo per i loro scheletri,
che erano essenzialmente massicci,
avevano questo robusto toro sopraorbitale;
erano un po' bassi,
fondamentalmente un po' tracagnotti.
E li possiamo -
i loro scheletri vengono ritrovati
nell' Eurasia occidentale,
fino a 50.000 anni fa.
Nello stesso periodo di tempo,
troviamo il Sapiens solamente in Africa.
Qualcosa inizia però a cambiare
intorno ai 50.000 anni fa:
iniziamo a trovare sempre più Sapiens
in Europa, e in Eurasia,
fino alla scomparsa totale
dei Neanderthal,
e troviamo solo Sapiens.
Ora, prima vi ho taciuto un dettaglio
molto interessante, e molto importante:
in Africa c'è molto meno Neanderthal
di quello che c'è oggi
in tutto il resto dell'Eurasia.
Questo cosa fa pensare?
Che quando il Sapiens uscì dall'Africa,
e colonizzò il globo,
incontrò questi Neanderthal e,
semplicemente, ci fece sesso:
e quindi, parte del genoma di Neanderthal
entrò nel pool genico del Sapiens.
E colonizzando tutto il globo,
lo portammo ovunque,
anche dove i Neanderthal
non c'erano mai stati:
in Australia, nelle Americhe.
E persino, probabilmente
con migrazioni successive,
di nuovo in Africa.
Quindi beh, forse vostra mamma,
vostro papà non erano -
anzi, sicuramente non ernano Neanderthal;
ma qualche vostro tris-tris-
trisnonno lo era, certamente.
Ora, tutte queste scoperte
sono state possibili grazie alle tecniche
che ci permettono oggi
di sequenziare il DNA antico.
Queste tecniche sono state messe a punto
soprattutto nel laboratorio
"Max Planck" di Lipsia,
guidato da Svante Pääbo,
che è anche l'istituto
dove ho fatto ricerca io per 10 anni.
Qui abbiamo sequenziato
moltissimi Neanderthal;
e in particolare, tre di questi
ad altissima qualità,
quasi comparabile a quella
dei genomi moderni.
Ma c'è uno dei fossili
forse più interessanti,
che morfologicamente
è apparentemente inutile,
è proprio una piccola falange
di un mignolino,
quindi ovviamente,
apparentemente insignificante,
ritrovata in una grotta in Siberia:
la grotta di Denisova.
Ora, in Siberia fa freddo;
e per questo motivo,
il DNA di questo individuo
si è conservato benissimo.
Quando i ricercatori
lo sono andati a sequenziare,
quello che hanno trovato è che era sì,
abbastanza simile a Neanderthal:
ma nemmeno tanto.
Fondamentalmente,
era più distante dai Neanderthal
di quello che ogni popolazione umana,
ogni individuo che prendiamo,
troviamo oggi nel globo,
è diverso tra loro, appunto.
Questo cosa suggerì?
Che, appunto, c'era qualche altra
popolazione arcaica,
che noi non conoscevamo dalla morfologia,
che viveva in Eurasia,
di cui non si aveva conoscenza prima.
Quindi, come facciamo a dire
dove vivevano questi individui,
che oggi vengono chiamati comunemente
"Uomini di Denisova"?
Per questo ci tornano utili
i genomi moderni.
Quando andiamo a guardare, per esempio,
nei genomi che troviamo
in Papua Nuova Guinea,
e vediamo che per ognuno
di questi papuasici -
o aborigeni australiani, anche -
fino al cinque percento del loro genoma
è derivato appunto dal genoma di Denisova.
Troviamo un po' meno Denisova in Asia.
E nell'Estremo Oriente,
si trovano altri frammenti di Denisova:
nei giapponesi di oggi, nei cinesi.
E questi frammenti sono
estremamente interessanti:
ad esempio, in Tibet,
il gene che conferisce
l'adattamento all'altitudine
è appunto di origine Denisova.
E questo ci fa pensare
che quando siamo usciti,
e abbiamo incontrato
tutte queste popolazioni,
alcuni di questi
ci hanno lasciato dei geni
che ci hanno permesso
di adattarci a nuovi ambienti.
Tra l'altro, in Tibet è stato
recentemente trovato del DNA di Denisova,
persino nei sedimenti.
Questo ci dà un po' un'idea migliore
di quello che era il globo
fino a 50.000 anni fa.
Quindi i Neanderthal,
i Denisova e i Sapiens,
che hanno incontrato
tutte queste popolazioni,
semplicemente hanno fatto sesso.
Ora, abbiamo visto
quanto sono utili i genomi moderni
per ricostruire questi scenari:
quindi, vi riporto nel vostro
viaggio immaginario in Europa,
in particolare in Islanda,
dove è stato effettuato
uno sforzo gigantesco
per caratterizzare il genoma
di moltissimi individui.
Questo ci ha reso possibile
fare uno studio,
un paio d'anni fa,
in cui abbiamo utilizzato
oltre 25.000 genomi umani,
e in cui siamo andati a caratterizzare
i frammenti Neanderthal di tutti questi.
E quello che abbiamo notato è che,
se mettiamo insieme in fila
tutti questi piccoli frammenti,
andiamo a ricostruire praticamente
il 50% del genoma di un Neanderthal
semplicemente utilizzando genomi moderni.
Ora, noterete che alcuni pezzi
di questi cromosomi
sono un po' vuoti di questo blu,
di questo frammento di Neanderthal;
e su questo ci tornerò dopo.
Vorrei soffermarmi, però,
su un dettaglio estremamente interessante:
quando andiamo a guardare tanti
di questi genomi di islandesi,
troviamo anche del Denisova;
persino negli europei,
quindi persino nei vostri genomi,
c'è del Denisova.
Poco, molto di meno
di quello che troviamo oggi
nel genoma delle persone
che vivono in Papua:
mettendo insieme tutti questi frammenti
ricostruiamo circa il tre percento
del genoma di Denisova.
Però, sostanzialmente,
tutti quanti condividiamo
parte del nostro genoma
con queste popolazioni arcaiche.
Ora, non sappiamo esattamente
come questo genoma di Denisova
tornò agli islandesi.
Però sappiamo -
con tutti gli eventi,
migrazioni e scambio genico -
che probabilmente tornavano,
in qualche modo,
attraverso migrazioni umane.
Ora vi starete probabilmente chiedendo
se è vero che, ovunque siamo andati,
abbiamo fatto sesso
con chiunque trovavamo.
E la verità è che vediamo
che non siamo stati gli unici:
un indizio interessante,
a questo proposito, è un altro osso,
anch'esso abbastanza insignificante
se uno lo guarda così,
trovato sempre nella grotta di Denisova.
Quando i ricercatori
lo sequenziarono, all'inizio,
sequenziarono il genoma mitocondriale.
Ora, il genoma mitocondriale
ci è lasciato da nostra madre;
e quindi, ci dice solo
la storia della linea materna.
E quindi, quando fu
sequenziato, inizialmente,
videro che il genoma
da parte di madre era Neanderthal,
quindi pensarono fosse Neanderthal
come come tutti gli altri.
Quando però fu sequenziato
il genoma nucleare,
quello che abbiamo visto
è che per ogni cromosoma
c'era una copia Denisova
e una copia Neanderthal.
E cosa vuol dire, questo?
Questo scenario è compatibile
con una sola possibilità:
questa era la figlia -
perché appunto apparteneva a una donna -
di una mamma Neanderthal
e di un papà Denisova.
Tra l'altro, dall'osso -
per quanto non diagnostico,
non si riesce a capire bene
a quale osso apparteneva -
dal suo spessore si riesce a dire
che questa donna visse almeno 14 anni.
Questo suggerisce, quindi,
che questi individui,
questi figli di queste prime coppie miste,
erano in grado di sopravvivere
fino a una certa età;
e quindi, probabilmente,
avevano una qualche forma
di nuclei familiari.
Ma questa non è l'unica,
antica coppia mista che troviamo:
se andiamo nell'Est Europa,
nelle grotte, in Romania,
o in Bulgaria, nella grotta di Bacho Kiro
abbiamo recentemente trovato
degli individui,
che datano più o meno 45.000 anni fa,
che è il momento in cui
i Neanderthal spariscono,
e il Sapiens inizia a trovarsi in Europa.
E quello che troviamo in questi genomi
è che ci sono dei frammenti di Neanderthal
davvero, davvero lunghi.
Ora, c'è un processo
chiamato ricombinazione, nel genoma,
che fa sì che in ogni generazione
il genoma si mischia un pochino.
Questo è lo stesso fenomeno
per cui tutti noi abbiamo
la copia di un cromosoma da nostra mamma,
e una copia di un cromosoma
dal nostro papà.
Però abbiamo solo dei pezzetti
dai nostri nonni,
e dei pezzetti ancora più piccoli
dei nostri bisnonni.
Utilizzando questa proprietà,
possiamo quindi datare più o meno
quante generazioni passarono
dopo che gli antenati
di questi Neanderthal vissero,
gli antenati di questi
individui Neanderthal.
E quindi, riusciamo a individuare
che quattro o sei generazioni prima
che questi individui morirono,
e lasciarono le nostre ossa,
ci fu un qualche trisnonno Neanderthal.
Quindi li cogliamo quasi nell'atto.
Ora, una cosa estremamente interessante -
che però, vi ho detto,
ci sono delle parti del genoma,
nei genomi moderni,
che non hanno Neanderthal.
Vediamo che anche in questi individui,
queste zone non hanno
frammenti di Neanderthal;
e questo suggerisce qualcosa
di estremamente interessante,
ci dà una finestra sulla vita
di queste popolazioni.
In qualche modo,
gli individui che avevano del Neanderthal
in queste zone del genoma
probabilmente vivevano non bene.
E nelle primissime generazioni,
quindi questi figli
di queste coppie miste,
questi nipoti non si riproducevano.
Forse vivevano di meno, non lo sappiamo;
ma ci dà un'idea che deve essere stato
un periodo particolarmente intenso.
E questo non è del tutto sorprendente.
Oggi vediamo che alcune
di queste varianti Neanderthal
ci lasciano delle malattie:
e persino il CoVid,
la variante che ci rende più suscettibili,
alcune persone che hanno
questa variante Neanderthal
è appunto di origine Neanderthal.
Ci tengo a dire che questo è diverso
da quello che osserviamo
per le popolazioni moderne,
dove non esistono
queste barriere riproduttive:
come abbiamo visto, siamo tutti
essenzialmente africani,
la nostra variabilità genetica è tutta,
essenzialmente, di origine africana.
E differiamo solamente
in alcuni tratti molto esterni
che si interfacciano con l'ambiente,
tipo il colore della pelle
e qualche cosa legata al metabolismo:
però siamo essenzialmente uguali.
Quindi, questo cosa ci suggerisce?
Sicuramente, che ci fu
un sacco di sesso fra le popolazioni.
Anche se - ho messo dei Cupido prima,
perché ci fu sesso;
ma non sappiamo davvero
la natura di queste interazioni.
Sappiamo invece che tantissime specie,
quando noi uscimmo dall'Africa,
andarono estinte,
dalle Americhe all'Australia.
Quindi non possiamo escludere
che ci fu violenza,
che questo sesso non fu
del tutto consensuale,
che ci furono stupri.
Non sappiamo cosa successe ai Neanderthal:
in fondo, non li vediamo
camminare oggi fra noi.
E potenzialmente, possiamo essere stati
dei competitori efficaci,
sottraendogli prede e territori.
Un po' come magari può essere successo
nel caso della tigre dai denti a sciabola.
Una cosa però sappiamo:
nel nostro passato, ci siamo
sempre mischiati talmente tanto
che oggi gli antropologi sono concordi
nel dire che il concetto di "razza umana"
è un costrutto, di fatto non esiste,
e su questo ci sono degli altri,
bellissimi TED e TEDx Talk
di Guido Barbujani e di Svante Pääbo.
Vorrei lasciarvi quindi
con un immagine, che è questa.
Per delle piccole parti del vostro genoma,
siete più vicini a un Neanderthal,
vissuto magari 100.000 anni fa in Siberia,
che ai vostri amici o ai vostri parenti
o al vostro vicino di casa.
Grazie.
(Applausi)